so Russell this is I suspect one of
those scripts that you pick it up and
you say oh my goodness I have to make
this movie oh my goodness how do I make
this movie
can you describe what it was like when
you first came across Nacho's screenplay
sure well I loved it and there was that
leap of faith you always have to make
when you're going to produce and finance
a movie and this looked like a bigger
leap than most it it looked like a chasm
but what was on the other side was so
cool that we had to go for it what does
he say it's about and why does he say
it's about in terms of taking the genre
the kind of romantic comedy genre and
turning it upside down well first of all
it's about alcohol a lot of it and he's
a avid drinker but he also appreciates
the damage that it can cause and he's
very sensitive to it so that was him
that was his main theme but he was he's
also into subverting genre and that's
the way he drags it to me really it's a
surreal film but it's it's so cleverly
pulled off because it keeps giving you
the perception that it's going to be a
genre film right and it keeps subverting
it and it just dragged you through the
whole story and and when I think about
it I think wow he made a surreal film
and we better not tell anybody about it
what was it status when your company got
involved it was about three or four
months prior to pre-production but there
was still some uncertainty about whether
the film would go because of the
financing and we were asked into
co-financed and produce a picture with
voltage our partners and he had
initially developed this not even as an
english-language movie is that right
this was originally developed as a
spanish-language film that nacho was
planning to make for under a million
dollars his agent
however got the translated version to an
and she immediately said yes and Jason
followed up almost immediately afterward
so instead of making it for $500,000 he
made it for about 15 times that so where
does that happen in your involvement is
an attached is she coming in are they
about to start shooting where where does
your company get in and what are the
problems that you have to solve well my
my biggest problem was convincing my
South Korean partners to spend several
million dollars on a movie about a
thoughtless American drunk who destroys
half of Seoul yeah how did you go about
selling that idea to them because I
suspect the answer is they came in they
came in and the answer is I well what I
told them was that it was a classic Anne
Hathaway fairy tale that would
undoubtedly make hundreds of millions of
dollars and they said sure we're in yes
the one thing that is noticeable if you
look closely the second time I've seen
this film is Anne Hathaway's costumes or
a little bagging a little loose and
that's for a reason isn't it well we did
she found out during the insurance exam
for the film that she was pregnant so
and that was that was what is an
insurance exam I've not heard that
phrase well you're going in there doctor
to make sure everybody else Dave inton
yeah and she didn't know she was
pregnant
and which could have thrown the whole
thing overboard but she decided to go
ahead bless her soul and and she did an
incredible job Russell levain thanks for
bringing us your movie